yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Yardbird I haven't played him
all that much recently we had stuff like
that and that was it was very much in
danger by the way this match am it's
this is game 79 and he's got a plus 3
score great we have seven drawers seven
drawers most of it yeah most of them
were the size of games okay um i
actually have to take on between after
if I immediately oh that's going to be
risky and it's very risky am I have to
check out be to where I completely
screwed up the move on him 9c 45 yeah
that's extremely problematic for me
check this orders for this first
yeah this is just probably close to
unplayable for black I can just play I
can take and play 50 maybe I
check if I if I can maybe maybe survive
quench xt5 but it looks I have to yeah
okay probably hear phone takes e6 then
and 95 is from the killing I have to
take me to I just this this up this is
totally screwed up i played this all so
far too quickly here you have to take me
to Queen takes be to also covers b5 it's
extremely sharp but it's what you have
to do now the bangko n term related
opening some if you if it if it goes
wrong it goes really wrong leather
platform for both sides here is success
also which i think just wins actually
six well maybe I can take take and play
[Music]
long castles
and you can calculate all kinds of
things and you know peace xrd 6mm can
you steer you don't have to think about
what zoopla a you just play the move
that you have to play and that's it ya
name is going Lisa either he has 95
actually have Knight f6 and then this
heaven I guess one I'd be six
[Music]
[Music]
Kim yeah whatever I'll take it check
[Music]
promise said that is here ok I can I can
under promote or what's the thing anyway
let's go here I thought you just anyway
let's focus on the actual position look
f1 is probably what you will play at the
end and then I still don't see a move it
to be honest the Kings no okay are you
just placed for the attack okay that's
possible so check I have to take this
and now okay threatening all kinds of
mayor won't be eight and my rook still
hangs
time morning no I don't see a move
really yep okay the rupee aids probably
probably the cleanest way
[Music]
to a five check takes a 4mm he doesn't
have a check in this position it's quite
amazing the queen is covering some stuff
Lexi ain't
check I am enter nail him okay no it was
lost anyone Angus resides it was lost
anyway no it's a draw this position is a
draw I don't believe this I Queenie six
wins okay but this is a draw really if I
capture it's a draw I of course yeah I
can't play Queen c6 I can't play 26 I
covered this now ah so he has to do this
and then just about make a job Wow queen
is six wins though Wow okay yeah it
wasn't an opening disaster ready now
after I completely forgot about about
this I have to check on me too I just
played too quickly Queen B 6 is the
normal move after something like oil up
or lexi three you can go to in b6 but
here you have to take and actually yeah
make white move this night and then go
from there here you can can play like
that that's kind of okay and this is
this is too risky because now he gets
all the play without the move c3 and I'm
just too slow likes development i mean i
have no development quite quite clearly
check and yeah you five was making
stronger it's just an absolutely
terrible position this this I thought
6 awesome but this is what I thought
actually and then just some 95 lakiya I
didn't see a move he played the the
morning J yeah it's technically pleasing
variation that also wins Jay I was just
a bit surprised that check yeah I
thought just maybe not I cook every one
not so much yes check this seems to win
I mean my back in position is just so
bad he also had this is attacked so he
has to change first and then then this I
can actually take Here I am check at
least without losing immediately check
check hmm yeah simply I'd simply didn't
see a move here as of course i saw that
i can take budget I had a I thought this
would win the queen but I'm covering
this from g8 I was just not seeing this
correctly okay wow thanks for watching